hello everybody Doug Walker here it's a
little rainy outside but Chicago's very
slowly turning into Seattle recently so
I'm just gonna film anyway this video is
mainly gonna talk about the top 11
nostalgia critic reviews that I will not
do because I get a lot of requests a lot
of people ask me to review a lot of
stuff and for the reasons I'm gonna
explain right now I don't want to do
them I don't think they're worth doing
so I start taking page from the book of
link ah right here I'm gonna count down
the top 11 reviews that I is the
nostalgia critic will not do I decide
not to do a sense of nostalgia critic
video because no no there's better
reviews that I think I could do so I'm
just sort of doing it as myself and just
sort of telling you which ones I don't
think are really worth doing so why
waste a time let's get started
[Music]
watership down that's just one of those
I don't really get why people want me to
review it I I saw when I was younger and
I though was good I thought actually for
a book this grim and this dark I thought
the movie actually captured it
relatively well the animation is good I
love the voice acting John Hurt's in it
I you know anything he touches I think
is gold so I don't know why so many
people want me to review it isn't
because it's really dark is it because
you know it's marketed as a kid's film
and yet rabbits getting drowned in dirt
and blood everywhere and stuff like that
I mean it's I I guess maybe that could
be a little funny okay I don't sound
funny but um you know maybe the idea
that this is supposed to be this very
fluffy innocent film and there's two
cute little rabbits on the front and the
fact that there's just constant death
and constant killing all throughout so I
don't know I don't think it's enough to
hold up for a review though and like I
said I think it's good I think it's a
decent movie so I don't know exactly why
so many people want me to review it but
it is one of those requests I keep
getting over and over and over so I'm
definitely not doing that one I like the
movie next a goofy movie now I think I
think I know why some people want me to
do this it's probably because whenever
Disney tries to do something really hip
and really with it it's it usually
backfires unbelievably and this one does
a little bit but I don't think actually
it's that bad actually it came out a
little past my time I think I was just
sort of starting high school around this
point so I wasn't really seeing you know
animated Disney films uh but I saw yours
later I saw when I was looking after
somebody's kid and it's okay it's decent
you know it could have been a lot worse
um and something actually I do like
about the film is that it's neat to see
Disney do its are like the same thing
with lilo and Stitch it's neat to see
Disney animation do current things like
I think it's the first time I've seen a
hot tub in a Disney film it looks really
odd I mean it's it's me but it's like or
or an RV you know and things like
so it's it's certainly for just that
reason but on top of that uh I think the
stuff it talks about is actually sort of
legit about a father trying to stay in
his son's life but the son wanting to
grow up and trying to let the Sun go but
still have some connection uh I think
that's all there and I think they
address it from the most part pretty
well I think it actually has some very
funny moments you know those songs I
don't really remember except for that
first my except for that after today's
song which is ungodly catchy and will
never leave your head but for the most
part I thought it was okay I don't think
there's enough for a review I think
there's only like a few jokes most of it
centering around that I don't know what
it is or that MC Hammer Prince Vanilla
Ice rock star whatever that guy was so I
comparing some jokes about that but
that's about it I don't think it's that
bad a movie so I don't know not doing
that one come on I'm the spider-man
cartoon now I'll admit I hate this
cartoon this is one of those cartoons
that came out the same time it's x-men
and Batman and then this piece of shit
comes along and it's trying to it trying
to do what they're doing but it's doing
it so horribly it feels like one of the
cartoons from like the 60s where there's
no pacing there's no good timing the
dialogue is really lame and it just
tries to throw a ton at you without
letting any of it really sink in now
with that say I know a lot of people
like the show great maybe you got into
it maybe need to get sucked into the
story I could I thought was really lame
DMH and I didn't think was especially
good either
um so there is a lot to talk about
the downside is and this is something
which your shows in general whenever I'm
gonna do coming out holy shit it's hail
there's fucking hail this is fucking
nuts like it's been nothing but rain
this whole summer and now we got Hale
fucking Hale and summer and tornadoes
have been coming down it's gen like that
it's it's fucking n times man it's
fucking n time it is crazy but I digress
hey I'll still do the room
you wasn't talking about spire man okay
spider-man well the the the cartoon
itself I see I never read the comics
much my brother was much more into the
spider-man comics so I was hoping I was
actually gonna sort of get into
spider-man like the comics the same way
that got into like the x-men comics
because I got into the x-men comics
through the cartoon and I was hoping
spider-man would do the same but it was
just so lame to me and they were
throwing so much at you that I didn't
care for it so but anyway why aren't I
doing cuz it sounds like gets a prime
the suspect to do because whenever I do
a show it has to be something that I
grew up with and that I watched I really
didn't watch that show and to
appropriately talk about it you have to
watch the show and you have to really
know what what goes on what the
repeating problems are and stuff like
that with a movie even if you haven't
seen it you can watch it and you know to
say what's wrong with it whether show
you really have to watch it like Captain
Planet despite the fact that was a bad
show I did what I don't know why there's
nothing else on that timeslot same thing
my full house I don't know why I watch
the show I had something it's like
cocaine for the eyes or something I have
no idea what kept bringing us back but
don't act like you didn't watch it
either so spider-man I didn't watch so I
would not be able to appropriately talk
about what's wrong with it or you know
what's good about it I won't be able to
address it fairly and I feel that just
be tripping you guys because it's not
giving you a fair review of the show so
that's the main reason I don't talk
about it hail stopped next one
[Music]
attack of the killer tomatoes / killer
Klowns from outer space the second one
particularly killer Klowns from outer
space I get a lot it's meant to be bad
guys it's like reviewing Evil Dead - or
army of Darkness there's no point
it makes fun of itself already it's
supposed to be silly the same thing with
the tag of the killer tomatoes by God
how many fourth wall jokes do they break
in that movie um you know there's sort
of classic B movies that are meant to be
silly they already are mocking
themselves I don't even know what else
to really say about I like both movies
actually I think they're both pretty
funny and chemical I haven't seen that a
long time I think I saw when I was a
little kid even as a little kid I knew
this is meant to be stupid this is meant
to be dumb I think at the very end when
like the two guys survived in the
ice-cream truck very predictable so it's
awesome I mean come on that's that's
pretty stupid that's meant to be stupid
so very basic if you haven't seen these
movies they're both pretty entertaining
check them out they're both funny yeah
so that that's why I'm not doing that
[Music]
number sir
toys now this is one of those movies I
saw it as a kid I saw it as an adult I
have no idea what to make of this movie
I I have no idea if it's really good or
really awful or or what I know it's a
movie the director really want to do for
a long time and you know it's talked
about for eons and he has I really
wanted to do and I finally got made and
just nobody knew what to make of it I
don't know what to make event um I guess
I would have liked a more interesting
story I didn't feel the story was that
interesting if you're gonna do something
this strange in this bizarre go for
something really abstract or go for just
a totally batshit crazy story or go for
something that really does have a very
complicated interesting plot don't try
to meet halfway I think that's what the
movie tried to do but because of that
you get something that's visually
interesting it looks awesome you know
it's got some nice music I recall um but
I don't know if there's much to make fun
of it's just kind of weird and even then
it's not like an extreme weird where
you're just constantly going what the
hell this is not sensitive it's it sort
of creates that world where this stuff
can happen and you sort of go with it
you know okay but there's no point where
you just point to the screen say no this
does not happen this is wrong this is an
insult this is terrible um at least I
don't when I saw it so just sort of all
I really remember about I just read the
visuals I remember Joan cues they act
and remember them trying to get army
toys in um I don't remember much else
and every time I see it I just I
remember what it looks like and I don't
remember leaving a really bad impact on
me I don't recall it having you know a
ton of jokes I can make fun of so that's
definitely what I'm not gonna do number
six
Nutcracker starring the Care Bears okay
after I did the third Care Bears movie
everybody sending me emails if there's
one more movie there's one more movie
here's why I'm not doing it
I'm only doing the theatrical films okay
I'm doing the ones that you know kids
went to they sat down they they saw it
in the movie theaters you know you had
to pay money to go see it you know that
that's where you suffer because you had
to pay money go into theater you got
shipped off so the Nutcracker one might
remember when it came out I remember it
came out like on the Disney Channel they
they shown it um it's stupid it's dumb I
remember it being dumb you know even as
a little kid I think I was getting the
Ninja Turtles by that point I always
thought God this movie needs Ninja
Turtles just ninja turtles come in oh
like deepest shit out of the Care Bears
inside just remember that so um I'm not
gonna review this one I try to stay away
from movies I sort of go directly to
video I try to do ones that more people
have seen you know or grew up with and I
know videos and DVDs now you know the
street - video DVD stuff is becoming
more and more popular now but back then
I don't think it was and I like to I
like to attack the stuff that we grew up
with so we can compare what we thought
back then to how it holds up now so yeah
I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna look at that I don't want
look anyway I'm done with Care Bears man
I'm due pretty cold bitch no more I'm
I'm done with that shit come on cats
don't dance now a lot of people say this
is a really bad movie and that sucks as
some people actually enjoy it okay um
for me I actually don't think it's that
bad a movie except for one major thing
and his major that's the main character
the main character is so bland and so
forgettable that it really brings the
whole thing down all your characters are
fine they're a lot of fun and they're
really creative and the animation is
great I really love the timing on this
animation I love the speed of this
animation I love this villain this sort
of Shirley Temple ish villain that looks
all nice and cute with him the cameras
are off she turns into this really mean
power-hungry monster that's funny I mean
that's really really funny
I like this weird bodyguard that she has
that seems larger than life and just the
way he enters and leaves he leaves
through the wall and comes through the
wall um a lot of that stuff I think is
very entertaining it's just the main
character and he is awful it's a
terrible main character I mean it's not
like a bad role model or anything like
that but he's just so bland so
forgettable and I understand that I
totally get that I don't think that's
enough to hold up for a review I think
there's enough things in there that
makes it fun it makes it entertaining
and some things are over the top of that
again that that's part of the fun um I
don't think it's actually that bad I
actually I'm actually glad I saw it I
thought I was actually relatively
entertaining um but yeah I agree main
character is crap and he's not fun but I
think it's okay I think it's an okay
movie actually so a lot of people keep
telling me to review it I'm not gonna do
it because that one character I don't
think that's enough and I don't actually
think he's the world's worst character
either right you can get much more
material out of a character who's like a
bad role model like the character from
airborne who was
now you know being a passive this all
the time but he still talks tough he
still sort of eggs people on and of
course he whatever pants is a person at
the very Abbey you know it's like oh
yeah those are real passive is there so
that kind of stuff I can make fun of
much more if it's just bland it's just
bland I mean there's not much you can do
with it so I'm not doing that Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles 3 shortest
explanation in the world james rolfe did
it he did a great he addressed every
single solitary little thing wrong with
it
there's nothing new i can bring next one
[Music]
The Brave Little Toaster
again like this movie I mean it's not
masterpiece or anything like that but
just for what it is I mean just I don't
know it's a weird story a toaster and a
bunch of other appliances they've been a
house too long and they've missed their
human companions or they go out to try
and find him okay weird but for such a
weird setup it's done pretty well I
actually like the fact that there's a
lot of scenes that don't have music in
it I like there's a lot of quiet scenes
in it there's a lot of atmosphere to it
uh and I really appreciate for that I
love that song at the end it was I think
it's called worthless or something where
they take the cars and they smash them
down to the cubes and you know whatever
I was in the Indy 500 it's like I love
that song that's a great song um and the
other characters I mean
well nothing phenomenal I remember them
I remember the vacuum ever the lamp I
remember the electric blanket very jon
lovitz as the radio uh I saw this a
while ago I mean I saw this one you know
I was just a low key and I still
remember it you know I think once in a
while growing up I saw it on TV you know
very briefly and I just watch a bit of
it
okay I mean I'm fine I mean maybe
there's some problems I don't know I
mean it is a weird setup for a story but
I thought it was fine now something that
a lot of people keep telling me to do
maybe I'll do I don't know is I guess
there's sequels to The Brave Little
Toaster the only title I remember is The
Brave Little Toaster goes
Mars okay what the fuck that's a weird
setup that title alone doesn't sound
real that sounds like a Simpsons made-up
title you know we have to defeat you
know the sequels this year we're being
beat it out by The Brave Little Toaster
goes to Mars I mean it's like okay
that's that I might do because that
sounds really stupid um but in terms of
the original spine I don't have any
problem with it no just straight off
toaster let it be a toaster number two
anything sonic related okay I did two
shows people two shows what more do you
want from me I can't do any more stop it
you know and what I thought was good I
liked one of them the other was really
friggin insane and like I said that you
got a lot of material from it but the
main reasons I don't do Sonic is that I
don't think there is that both those
shows were nostalgia I grew up with both
those shows so and I watch them both so
I can talk about it um with anything
else it's all too current and again it
has to be a show that I grew up with and
have some idea about you know so I can
properly represent it I didn't grow up
with all these other sonic shows as much
as people say they're terrible and say
they're god-awful I believe you I'm sure
they're really horrid but I didn't grow
up with them I didn't watch them I guess
there's a ton of other a sonic movies
and stuff like that I get sonic must
have like this really you know hardcore
determined fanbase because just
constantly I get people have to review
it I guess Lewis gets you know people
ask me to review sonic comics all the
time and just everything sonic I never
liked the video game confession I think
the line gets the most views again is
the sonic one so I mean I could do it
and whatever get the views going through
the the roof but I just I don't think
I'd be able to properly talk about it um
you know I am I was a Mario kid growing
up to I mean that's one of the reasons I
can't talk about the sonic games that
much because I didn't grow up with a
sonic games I played once in a while but
you know that I was a Nintendo kid I was
played with Nintendo um so yeah I think
the major thing is that they're way too
current I didn't grow up with these
shows and with the movies I'm sure
they're bad but I feel like I've done
sonic already I don't think there's much
else to talk about sort of like me going
and doing another Mario so that's
another thing I'm not going to I'm not
going to do the other Mario show while
we're on the subject I'm not gonna do
Super Mario Bros 3 and I gonna do Super
Mario World
it's it's just the Super Show again that
it's there's your review hey did you
like the Super Mario Brothers Super Show
here it is again put a three on it now
put world on it their exact same show
just sort of a different setting a few
more characters so that's it now I'm not
covering any of those the number one
thing I will never do in this house your
critic review on is Star Wars Episode
one The Phantom Menace and I know I know
there's a ton of things that make fun of
I know there's a ton of things I can
point out and say it's wrong and stuff
like that here's the thing everybody's
done it everybody has pointed out every
single solitary little thing wrong with
that movie the most I can do is just
draw comparisons to other films and say
this is like the Phantom Menace because
everybody's talked about red letter
media good god I mean I think that
review was longer than the movie it's
like eight hours I mean I can't say
anything about it everybody's already
said it um if sort of like the same
reason why I won't do the Ninja Turtles
3 review because james rolfe already
said everything that needs to be said
about it I mean just in great detail I
can't add anything to it unless I feel
there's something that I can bring to it
and nobody else has brought and I can do
sorry there's a different spin um it's
not we're doing that's one of the
reasons why you know but before I review
something I you know like maybe one of
our reviewers did I watch it I do check
it out to see if there's anything else I
can bring it if it turns out they've
already done it perfect and there's
nothing else I can talk about I'm not
going to talk about because somebody
already did it fine are probably better
than I did and it's the same thing with
Phantom Menace everybody's talked about
everybody's reviewed it everybody knows
what's wrong with it everybody's made
the jokes they make much better jokes
than I can about it so I'm never
do Star Wars Episode one the same thing
about Episode two in Episode three just
everybody's already rifted to death I
mean they I don't think I can bring that
much if I really felt I could bring
something to it I would but it's been
done and everybody's done it so yeah
definitely you know no more asking about
that no more asking about Star Wars
Episode one I'm never gonna do it so
there are these guys those are the top
eleven dystocia Creek episodes I will
never do I will never review I have no
interest in doing them at all so stop
asking now you know what's gonna happen
again I'm gonna get all sorts of new
other reviews to constantly ask to do
well okay and then I'll make another top
11 list so there it is guys thank you
for watching I hope you enjoyed and
that's it
take care